yo siempre he querido conocer a popeye
popeye guau guau cuando se lo cuento a
mis amigos yo creo que me miran con cara
súper rara piensan en el fondo que estoy
un poco loca pero de verdad créeme si os
digo que en esta vida pueden suceder
cosas sencillamente extraordinarias como
conocer a popeye
para mí popeye rompe con el estereotipo
tradicional de los superhéroes porque de
entre todas las armas que podría haber
elegido para afrontar los retos de su
existencia como por ejemplo la espada y
el escudo un traje antibalas o una capa
para volar él se desmarca y usa la
espinaca
quién hubiera dicho que algo tan
sencillo y qué pasa tan sumamente
inadvertido pudiera convertir a alguien
en superhéroe pues sí popeye supo ver el
potencial de la espinaca y la emplea
para transformar su realidad
este es el tipo de superhéroes que
necesitamos para afrontar los retos de
la sociedad del presente y del futuro
y digo super héroe subrayó porque
realmente es muy complicado hacer un
ejercicio de observación y de
aprendizaje profundo sobre lo que nos
rodea y trascender así el conocimiento
elemental que tenemos sobre las cosas
y mucho más difícil aún en los tiempos
que corren donde estamos sometidos a
prisas a estrés a sobre información todo
esto hace que pasemos de puntillas sobre
las cosas verdad y que nos cuesta
muchísimo adquirir un conocimiento
verdadero un ejemplo de ello lo muestra
este experimento en el que se relata la
actividad cerebral de un alumno a lo
largo de los siete días de la semana
podemos observar que hay momentos del
día donde el cerebro está activo y
receptivo sin embargo hay otros en los
que la actividad bien pudiera parecerse
a la de un encefalograma plano
os imagináis qué momentos del día son
estos
las clases precisamente el lugar donde
la transmisión de conocimientos debiera
ser muchísimo mayor
por tanto se convierte en un reto
motivarnos y alentarlos para el
aprendizaje y solo así sin embargo
seremos capaces de trascender lo y
usarlo como una herramienta realmente
resolved ahora de problemas
transformadoras del mundo
cuando conseguimos esto
dejamos de ver en la espinaca una simple
planta y pasamos a ver su potencial uso
como un plasma que funciona para reparar
las paredes de un corazón enfermo
gracias a estas ramificaciones que tiene
su hoja y que permiten que la sangre
circule por ellas
increíble verdad un reto a la altura de
los de superhéroe de esos que cambian el
mundo un mundo que ha evolucionado
gracias a ideas revolucionarias como
esta como así lo evidencian las
distintas revoluciones industriales que
hemos sufrido a lo largo de los siglos
y es también muy evidente el papel que
ha jugado la robotización en toda esta
transformación los robots han llegado
para quedarse y desde su aparición nos
han permitido entre otras cosas reducir
el número de horas que trabajamos a la
semana con una caída de más de 30 horas
en poco más de siglo y medio
esto entre otras cosas nos ha facilitado
una mayor calidad de vida
y queremos más queremos una nueva
revolución robótica
necesitamos que los robots no solo se
incorporen a nuestra vida laboral sino
que también queremos que coexistan con
nosotros en casa en nuestro ocio y como
no queremos incorporarlos en nuestro
sistema sanitario para garantizarnos una
vida más larga y de mayor calidad
hay quienes piensan que los robots del
presente están sobradamente preparados
para afrontar estos retos y sin embargo
no es para nada así
si nos fijamos en los robots más
avanzados del planeta descubriremos que
tienen serios problemas simplemente para
caminar y manipular objetos
reproducir habilidades de locomoción y
manipulación en los robots es una tarea
sumamente compleja como también lo es
desarrollar prototipos robóticos que nos
permitan restaurar nuestras capacidades
locomotoras cuando las hemos perdido
y la cuestión aquí es cómo afrontó estos
retos como rompe con el paradigma de la
robótica tradicional y consigo
evolucionar
la respuesta está al alcance se trata de
observar alrededor y de buscar esas
herramientas transformadoras como dita o
popeye con su espinaca
así si observamos la naturaleza
descubriremos que la mayor parte de los
seres que la habitan son blandos todo lo
contrario a lo que sucede con la
robótica tradicional que es
eminentemente rígida este es el
paradigma que tenemos que abrazar el de
la robótica blanda
los robots blandos y flexibles se
adaptan a las tareas de una forma
muchísimo más adaptativa las resuelven
de forma eficaz como las hacen los la
mayor parte de los seres blandos de la
naturaleza
son fascinantes la cantidad de
aplicaciones que este tipo de robótica
nos brinda y que ya están revolucionando
el planeta por ejemplo podemos
desarrollar prótesis para reemplazar un
miembro perdido mucho más sofisticadas
que las actuales y que nos permiten
restaurar nuestra habilidad locomotora
de una forma muy eficaz
es también indudable el salto
cualitativo que se produce en la
manipulación por ejemplo cuando
introducimos elementos blandos en la
fabricación de manos robóticas que cada
vez se parecen mucho más a las humanas
no sólo en el aspecto sino en destrezas
los animales son también referencia para
la robótica blanda podemos recrear el
comportamiento de pulpos capaces de
agarrar preparar nadar con todas esas
aplicaciones que esto conlleva
y así también podemos recrear el
comportamiento de un pequeño gusano del
tamaño todavía más pequeño que la yema
de un dedo capaz de acceder a cualquier
espacio recóndito y explorarlo
y quizás más fascinante aún es que
existen robots compuestos de material
blando comestible
que pueden llegar a depositar el
medicamento en cualquier parte de
nuestro cuerpo
detectar obstrucciones e incluso
eliminar las aplicaciones todas ellas
totalmente fuera del alcance de la
robótica tradicional
pero hay mucho más esto no son los
únicos retos a los que se enfrenta este
tipo de robótica
la robótica holanda apoya el desarrollo
de las habilidades quizás más anheladas
en los robots que son las que están
íntimamente relacionadas con la emoción
los robots blandos y flexibles favorecen
el lenguaje corporal su naturaleza
blanda les permite organizar sus
movimientos en el tiempo de manera que
resultan sencillamente emocionales y
para nosotros como seres humanos que
somos los robots que nos transmiten
emociones y nos transmiten empatía son
simplemente perfectos por encima de
otras muchas destrezas
y no nos quedamos aquí
la robótica blanda afronta el reto de
reproducir el comportamiento de los
seres quizás más olvidados del planeta
tan olvidados que muchas veces ni
siquiera aparecen en las
representaciones del arca de noé
de entre todos los seres vivientes de
toda carne llamados a embarcar en el
arca para la supervivencia de la vida
quizás algunos pasaron desapercibidos
las plantas
y sin embargo algo tan sutil y dedicado
como un tallo puede ayudarnos a
revolucionar la robótica asistencial
y yo misma me lo hubiera creído hasta
que un grupo de científicos con los que
trabajo me enseñaron el arma que se
esconde detrás de este hilo que tiene
forma de ramitas
se trata de una aleación con memoria de
forma y se llama así porque tiene la
capacidad de contraerse cuando se
calienta y de recordar y recuperar su
longitud original cuando se enfría
convenientemente distribuidos estos
hilos a lo largo de un dispositivo
robótico que se acopla a nuestro brazo y
que se llama exoesqueleto estos hilos
funcionan de la siguiente manera cuando
hago pasar una corriente por ellos se
calienta al calentarse se contraen y
permiten la flexión del brazo cuando
cesa esa corriente se enfría por tanto
se longa y permiten recuperar la flexión
original
este tipo de dispositivos está
revolucionando la robótica de
rehabilitación y permite que personas
por ejemplo que han sufrido un ictus
sean capaces de rehabilitar de forma muy
eficiente sus miembros afectados
frente a otras soluciones robóticas más
convencionales por ejemplo basadas en
motores este tipo de solución resulta
ser muchísimo más ligera totalmente
silenciosa y muy muy económica para que
os hagáis una idea un metro de este
material viene costando lo que un kilo
de espinacas
y no es lo único que tiene en común con
esta planta ambas son armas que han sido
usadas por superhéroes para transformar
su realidad
definitivamente yo creo que los sueños
se cumplen quién me iba a decir que
durante todos estos años de trabajo
científico tenía a popeye aquí al lado
cuando se lo cuente a mis amigos no se
lo van a creer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]